what was it like growing up in north
korea why did you want to leave
so
north korea or mostly when i describe it
it's not like even different country
it's like a different planet
right they don't in this 21st century
they don't have
electricity right and they if you look
at the satellite photos it's the darkest
place on earth like literally
so i say like we have earth day every
day in north korea
very good for the environment
and we don't even know what internet is
like people have no clue right
and they don't have any other
information so north korea literally
calendar begins when kim your son was
born
now when the jesus christ was born right
and they don't even tell us that we are
asians
they say uh you are kimierzong race
really yeah
that's the the racism or
you know the highest so
they do not let you know what the house
would look like and i didn't even not
know africa different continents i never
seen the map of the world wow all i knew
was north korea
americans but they say american masters
that's like a one word really yeah so
how did you know that you had it bad or
how did you know that you wanted to
leave
i did not know i had a bad because i i
remember they were showing us these
footages of americans and showing the
homeless people right and they look at
america there's no birds because
everybody ate the older birds so i heard
that yeah
we didn't though um actually that's not
that's that's not completely untrue
what was it the passenger pigeon
you guys know this yeah they used to go
out with nets and just catch pigeons and
then eat them and they drove it to
extinction interesting so that actually
happened but we we do have a lot of
birds and there's pigeons everywhere
yeah like there's pigeons on boats
exactly
yeah so so what happened
and they show they they cannot they like
eat the snow because they are so hungry
basically they are describing what we
are having in north korea
and
and then in schools like that like they
say there are four american investors
you killed two american ambassadors the
how many american ambassadors left his
care then as a younger you said two
american ambassadors so even though when
they teach you math it has to be
propaganda interesting everything has to
lead to one thing is brainwashing us wow
so north korea is like apparently a
religion it's a kingdom right yeah they
keep your sons of parents were
christians so he copied the bible said
i'm a god i love you so much so i'm
giving my son kim jong
his body dies but no no he's experienced
with us forever therefore he knows what
you think how much hair you in your head
wow i mean if the people believe in
bible i mean why would you blame people
not believing that right because they
cut out every information so people do
not know even what is critical thinking
is so how did it come to be that you
decided to leave hunger i was 13 years
old
i was luckily by then i was living this
border town and at night time i could
see lights coming from china and i was
thinking
maybe if i go build a light store i
might find something to eat wow
i did an interview with some new
zealanders who rode motorcycles through
north korea into south korea have you
ever did you ever hear of them no
so they organized what what these
individuals wanted to do was
travel motorcycle they wanted to ride
motorcycles along famous route so they
did like the silk road they did the
coast of south america and then they
they wanted to do
through north korea into south korea but
there's no real roads to do it so it's
very difficult
but they were telling me how
when they went through there they were
saying like this is what they explained
to me and so this is hearsay and i just
well you know you can correct me that if
there was like a farm
and a cow died yeah they couldn't eat
the cow no that someone would have to
come and take the meat and spread it
around the country evenly to everybody
or something like that no
what would happen so north korea there
are three it's a cat system they begin
with the communism right let's make
everyone equal but now they got
ended up with 50 different classes
within the same people 50 yeah wow they
divide three big categories and they
divide the subclasses to 50 different
classes and you never can go you can
only go down so that's how they prevent
people mixing around being married
there's no like you marry up if you
marry somebody in a different class you
go down with them you don't go up with
them wow so in that case so if the so
one of the execution that my mom saw was
this young man he had tb tv is a huge
problem in north korea managing
tuberculosis yeah so he uh ate the cow
in the farm and then they were executing
him
for eating for eating meat yeah so i
never ate beef in my life because cows
are supposedly working the farmers so
you don't have a private property
nobody can own anything we cannot own
house we cannot own cars house nothing
we can own right it's a communism so you
own nothing and you must be very happy
yeah that great reset looks better every
day doesn't it really it completely
freezes you yeah it's a liberation you
own nothing yeah so
this if the cow dies of course the
officials got to come and take it for
them and if the normal people eat it
you're gonna be executed what do they do
with the cow the official type elites
they divide with themselves
so they they take it for like the upper
caster yeah open cast takes it and they
call even the shocking thing is like
this uppercase don't even call normal
north koreans are people they call us
like trash rubbish what that's how we do
north korea different cats treating each
other
wow is that because of like uh like
historical family things like oh you
weren't part of the revolutionary party
and that's how you end up in a lower
class so this is like what like made me
very sad america is like here all about
white girls like your ancestors on the
slaves therefore you must be guilty and
you are privileged in north korea the
same thing because maybe my great great
great grandfather was a landowner or
not fighting for the communist side
then they said your blood is tainted
forever
now might how do you choose your
ancestors right you can never do that
how do you choose your skin god you
cannot do that and so they punish you by
being associated to that it's called
guilt by association right i mean
we're we're going through this and it's
getting worse so i definitely want to
talk about the comparison between
wokeness and stuff but we'll we'll get
there so
you were 13 and you were hungry yeah and
you saw china and you decided to leave
so how long did it take what did you do
from there
so
i was initially gonna go with my own
sister who was 16 years old i was 13
and then one day i got really sick so
they took me to hospital and by north
korea we don't have like electricity
x-rays right doctor just literally rubs
your belly
and then nurse is using one needle to
inject everyone wow people don't die
from cancer in north korea we die from
hunger and infection mostly
and then they operated on me that day
without any anesthesia and then they
said
it's appendix but it's okay people
caught bones in order with any
anesthesia is a common thing
so i woke up and they were like no you
see you got malnutrition and infection
inside you
they closed me back and then i i could
not go right i might mostly die from
infection so she had to leave so she
escaped first with her friend
and then was there retaliation from the
government for your family it was too
quick and the another thing is that in
north korea a lot of people die from
starvation so they say oh i'm gonna go
to work and then father leaves home and
he doesn't come back and he died on the
road to work
so this appearance is a very common
thing for the people you know death is
like always near i mean you see the
death bodies on the streets every day
it's like trash right
so
i never thought that was like you know
i'm normal i thought it was
in the morning when you go to train
station they're like so many bodies left
died and then they just collected like
woods right they are very
bodies get very rigid and just put them
together and then they don't even
like bother to bury them just like put
on like on the one side
and you see like rats eating human flesh
you see these children chasing these
rats they're eating human eyes first
then somehow these rats have disease so
children die then rats eat us back this
cycle between rats and kids eating each
other
yikes yeah okay so after the hospital um
you're still 13 at this time yeah and
then you know what's what happened next
so i found a note that she my sister
left me and said go find this lady she's
gonna help you to go to china so
i that was like right after i got out of
hospital i took my stitch i was like now
walking very worse there but i went to
my mom to find her you took your own
stitches out no they did and then the
next day i
with my mom and to the lady we found her
and then she said oh i can help you to
go to china
but just don't tell them that you are
mom and daughter
and then just tell them your order than
like 13 right they say you're maybe 18
or 19 and told to my mom you're like 35
she was in her 40s i had no clue why
they were doing that but which was they
were selling us wow and traffickers
yeah so what so
so what happens next
so i cross this frozen uh river yalu
river and i mean there are guards with
the machine gun standing there is gonna
shoot you if you cross but because the
human traffickers drive the guards we
were able to go and as soon as we
arrived in china the first thing was my
mom being raped in front of me
but the thing is i never so there's no
sex education in north korea right i
don't even know the word sex by then i
don't even know what kiss was like
love doesn't exist we don't know the
concept of love in north korea
now that that sounds like the most
villainous thing i've ever heard yeah
they i mean we know love but it's only
love when we have love for the dear
leader of course in the reaching fund
but they do not talk about women's love
so i never heard my mom says like i love
you ever i never knew that was a word
that people used that that's something i
didn't know i mean i i still imagined
with all of the problems of north korea
people
you know i i have this vision of this
like dystopian world where the the young
men and women run and embrace and
they're like if the guards find us it'll
all be over like human emotion still
exists in this place people still
understand these concepts but i suppose
if the if if the authorities the powers
suppress knowledge from you you can't
have these concepts so this is the thing
like in north korea there's no concept
from compassion we have no concept for
human rights liberty love you know all
these things it's like why georgia ever
talks about who controls the language
controlling those right double speak
they write a new language for you so
therefore you don't you're not capable
understanding this
concept that we know here
so now you leave north korea you find
yourself in china but you've been sold
to traffickers yeah so now you have
another problem yeah i know and this i
mean it it it sounds like that's
this is it's hard to quantify but it
sounds worse
no hunger is the worst thing any i mean
if you don't you die yeah
so
in china i remember like they told us
they don't even bother to force us right
like oh if you don't want to be sold you
can go back to north korea
in
which would mean death yeah which means
you're gonna even if you don't get
caught you're gonna die from starvation
anyway and one thing that changed my
mind was for the first time in my life i
was seeing a trash can
and i did not know what it was right
what is that one thing and like where
you throw things like what is trash like
things that you don't need like what do
you mean you have things to throw away
that's when i was like i told my mom i
want to stay and they sold my mom for
less than hundred dollars
in 21st century
so you were separated from your mom yeah
and they sorted me for less than 300
and like because i was virgin and that
was something valuable in china so
that's how i got separated from
everybody and became alone
so then uh how long were you in in the
situation for
almost two years
yeah and that's when i brought my mom to
me i made a deal with the human
trafficker who bought me and i was gonna
kill myself but he said
oh if you become my mistress i'm gonna
help you to get your family
so i did and he brought my mom back from
a farmer that he sold
and he brought my sick father from north
korea oh wow so he then brought your
father and your mother into china yeah
or the mother your mom was in china but
your dad then came yeah and uh
so what happens next you know we'll just
we'll make our way to how you made to
america you know yeah i know it's a long
journey uh but my father had uh this uh
colon cancer he got from the prison camp
and he passed away uh before the beijing
only begin 2008 i remember the world was
celebrating but like north koreans you
have to be invisible you are always
scared to get caught by the authorities
so he passed away i buried his ashes
around 3am in the middle mountain i was
14 years old
and then one year later we met
missionaries
from south korea and they said
oh if you become christian we're going
to help you to be free
and then i was thinking like why do i
have to keep believing in something to
be saved but you know you're so
desperate that didn't matter even if
they told me you gotta believe in water
i'm gonna believe in the rock water
whatever it was so i became christian i
i proved my faith to them and they told
us we gotta walk across the globby
desert
and then if you're lucky enough not to
die from the cold because it was minus
40 degrees in february in the middle of
desert
and then if we don't get caught by the
guards
then we might survive so i don't know
the probability of making that journey
and now nobody going that mongolia a lot
it's too risky nobody does it so then
you went to the mongolia route where did
you end up after after that
so after mongolia we were in the
detention center several months and then
they bring in mongolia
they were moving around and then they
brought us to south korea then they make
us go through this insane process of
screening like they check if you're a
spy or not are you actually north korean
or not and then they put us in this
training three-month program
and tell us that americans are not
bastards
[Laughter]
south korea is not colonized by america
like you know they tell us what like
bank tell me atm machine and i literally
thought somebody inside the machine gave
me money right everything is such a
thing and in north korea we don't know
what bank is
so just tell us how to take a subway
like tara's like we are like babies we
are adults but babies never seen
anything like this
when you uh first got out of north korea
were you surprised by the kind of foods
that they had in china yeah
it was shocking like
yeah describe your experience what was
like the first thing you had or what was
the most shocking thing about it but the
thing is you think
when you are starving like thank god you
think you're gonna eat a lot but your
stomach is not useless oily fatty food
so i remember i was throwing up
constantly and i get because i've never
seen this many cars and buildings in my
life north korea 90 70 percent of those
are not peeps and only of them are in
pyongyang too so never seen a traffic
and never seen a like crosswalk right
so
i mean but the thing is also i lost
everything by the time i was in china
like i was a slave so it wasn't
i could enjoy anything there i was every
day was a survivor i remember like every
day i feel like i live thousand years
today
every day i goes by and before i go to
sleep i put on my shoes on
i always have to look for the extra when
the police comes where do i run where
they jump so ready to run every single
day like you live like that so now
you've made it to south korea they put
you through this screening they want to
make sure not a spy but was there a
point where they finally opened the
doors and said
freedom is yours
yeah what was that like scary
it was so painful
so scary yeah
i mean like they remember i remember
they said like for the first time so
introduce yourself and in north korea we
don't say i
like it we don't allow to say i we said
like we like water even though that's
because
that's like the meme
it's not a meme's actually no no there's
there's a joke where we make fun of
communists by replacing the letter i
with we
oh they totally do that wow really yeah
and then like nobody asks you what do
you think in north korea right so they
tell you your favorite color is red
because a revolutionary color
your favorite country is north korea
because your favorite food is this right
so now in south korea they say oh if you
don't know just tell us your favorite
colors like what the heck is that
do i suppose know what's my favorite
color so thinking for yourself
was something not trained it was hurting
my brain
it was so painful by literally saying
being free is not easy like if i was
guaranteed that i'm gonna have frozen
like enough potato if i go back to north
korea i would go back wow wow really it
was hot so like if you if you could have
survived you would have chosen to go
back yeah
for sure in the beginning yeah in
several years time i would have gone
back it was very painful to be free but
you you you learned you figured it out
you adapted i adapted i i learned like
what freedom was you know it for me to
learn freedom was like responsibility
and once i made that connection it
became like under more manageable right
but it's scary like in north korea when
you're born your life is determined for
before you're born based on your class
your parents everything so
what do you mean you choose your own
major right like they say what school do
you want to go to i don't know so what
major do you want to do what do you do
with your life i'm like do i have to
know
can just somebody tell me what to do i'm
very good at like being followed
it seems like we're seeing uh this
transformation united states where young
people want exactly that they want to be
told what to do they want the government
to do it for them or
they've gone uh a lot of young people
especially the millennial generation so
not not not so young anymore
in in like my life i was always told you
have to go to school you have to go to
college you have to do these things and
everyone kept trying to tell me what i
was supposed to do and for me i was
no i'm not going to do it but a lot of
people i know
went to college and just did what they
were told
when they get out of college they ask
now tell me what to do yeah so they're
not used to being out there in the
wilderness on their own and of course
this is very very very different from
say north korea
but it's part of this this shift i
suppose
where we used to be
i mean americans are fairly obstinate
you know don't tell me what to do i'll
do what i want but we're starting to see
that shift now so we're really close to
getting into modern politics but so i'll
just ask you this so how did you end up
you know so you're you're you're
adapting to south korea at what point
did you decide now i'm gonna make an
even bigger journey and choose for
myself to go to america oh
so i invited to a conference that was uh
in ireland
you know dublin and and it was a free
conference so they wanted to it's like a
youth leaders like a leadership
conference every country participates so
they asked north korea they called up
north korea and ms in london would you
send a delegation from north korea and
then they said we only can send three
because you have to spy on each other so
two is a lot easier to run but three
like you're watching or i'm watching we
are watching everybody right so it's
like we only can send three and they're
like okay how about we sponsor two you
sponsor one and recognize you know so
they were like okay we're gonna bring
these defectors then it's cheaper for
them
very practical so they invited me for
free
and then
i decided to be a speaker i applied to
this speaker it was very hard to become
a speaker and the speech that i gave
became very very violent and i was in
the university in south korea so that
led me to write a book and penguin
randomized was in new york so they
brought me to write a book in new york
and then i wanted to continue my
education and i they told me there's a
school at colombia was in new york
so so here you are yeah
that's how i'm here so the interesting
thing i suppose now is that uh you come
here you go to college the the current
culture war in the united states is
there's a very negative depiction of
colleges that they're embracing critical
theory marxist ideology and wokeness
sounds
like there's there's similar aspects to
what you experienced with um the
ideology being you know told what you
can and can't like and things like that
not identical obviously but well before
the show you said that the woke was
crazier
yeah i think that's what i said i could
be the fox news like north korea is not
even just nuts
this is uh i mean where do i even begin
but i mean it just entire four years
i was
i mean so in north korea by time when i
was born the revolution happened such a
long time ago people
are not passionate believers of
communism right collectivism they just
so much fear if you don't you get
executed so you have to do it
and like one thing first thing my mom
told me as a younger was don't even
whisper because the birds and mice could
hear you
and she was like your tongue is the most
dangerous weapon that you have
the things you say is not gonna just
only kill you it's gonna kill three
generations of our family or together so
be careful what you say right when i go
to school in the morning she would not
say oh be careful with the strangers be
careful with your mouth
i
i'm worried that we're headed in that
direction exactly you know with uh with
censorship with big tech with people
scared to speak out there are a lot of
people that say you know i i was
tweeting about anonymity i wasn't really
tweeting about anime but i was tweeting
about people who don't use their names
on social media and people said i'm
scared that i'll lose my job i can't
risk my job and my life from speaking
out
and if people
don't speak out we we slowly slip into
the nightmare
version of whatever that is where
the thing is yeah the things you're
describing yeah this is how we go there
this is how it begins
wow
yeah that's what i like at colombia oh
this is how the revolution began
right because
i mean at columbia this genuinely these
kids feel like they are so oppressed
they get triggered they actually cry
right by the injust they fear how they
are so oppressed and they are the
victims and they're not faking it they
really really truly believe in the thing
is what makes me so sad is that north
koreans have to be brainwashed because
we don't have any information
here on youtube of your finger you have
entire history what's stalling it what
the mouth is you have know what this rod
has taken us to humanity but these
people are so completely brainwashed
they think white men are the source of
every single evil that we have
i suppose i think it's uh
scarier to me that you can warn us and
say hey this is how the revolution
started in north korea hey this is what
it's like when you have this communist
utilitarian system
and no matter how many times we scream
it there are a lot of people in this
country that reject the idea that your
warnings matter and they actively pursue
these situations i suppose they think
they'll be like the higher caste maybe
those who live in pyongyang
they have paved roads yeah they have
electricity yeah but they'll probably
just end up being the farmers and the
outskirts who are executed for speaking
out improperly oh yeah they get so much
purges in pyongyang so i think but the
thing is like north korea designed
starvation right it's like a hunger
games there are 13 districts and there's
a capital right on purpose kim jong-un
starves us like the other way kim
jong-un admitted that 11 million north
koreans are severely managed he never
did that before but now he doesn't
bother hiding it like yeah we have like
almost 60
60 of the population are severely
managed why is doing that because one
missile test that he does he can feed 25
million north koreans for entire year
from 2017 he did 40 tests
why if we just cut down a few tests
nobody have to die in north korea why i
don't so this is what i can't understand
and maybe maybe you'll you'll have some
insight having obviously been from the
country
wouldn't it be better for
the the party for kim jong-un for his
his close circle wouldn't they be
wealthier if if north korea was
successful and prosperous with a
well-fed population with new
technologies and electricity wouldn't he
live better and safer no but then he
cannot be a god
right right now
you think about it when you're full then
you are starting to think about meaning
of life you can think it was philosophy
music art right but with north koreans
every day they don't care what's going
on am i gonna be able to find it next to
me or not am i gonna make it tonight to
naomi that's all they care so people
entire population is dedicated surviving
so now kim jong-un has no internal
challenges it's not like other countries
there's internal any region there's no
one single distance in north korea have
you ever heard that there's a house
arrest no
what's his
what's his goal what does he want
wasn't he educated in the west in
switzerland yeah it's a psychopath he
knows how humans should be treated
that's the thing like it's so he's a
psycho but he knows how people should
supposed to be treated but he doesn't
right he goes there he's a he thinks
he's a god i think so because a lot of
people who met him when they're younger
they call him like little janitor right
yeah like so everybody's like below him
so i don't think he's just completely
himself brainwashed that he's a god
so do you think the us is uh i mean the
u.s is massive
how many how many people uh do do we
know the population of north korea in
america or the the population of north
korea do we do 25 million 25 million
yeah so i mean the u.s has about 10
times the population
uh
it's it seems far far-fetched i suppose
or maybe people just believe it can't
happen here but do you think that what
you're seeing in the us will bring us to
a a situation like north korea i'm lying
right now living in chicago yeah i mean
this chicago is a war zone you cannot
even walk out in during the middle of
day in the downtown where there's police
cars right there people commit crime
and this as i mean you say system is
broke like literally during the lootings
right police standing there and this
guy's destroying nike store in the
magnificent maya and why don't you
arrest them
and then my friend said like why don't
you arrest them and then he's like i
know who torres and this guy just
started shooting at him whoa police is
right and he had to run for his life
he has a video
i'm not joking like
oh my gosh he was started shooting at
him and police are standing there
nothing thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you